شهدت العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم في اليوم
السابع عشر للمواجهات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع قصفا جويا للجيش السوداني على
مواقع لقوات الدعم السريع التي ردت
بمضادات الطائرات بين مدى اشتباكات عنيفه
في عدد من المواقع بالخرطوم بين الجانبين
ياتي هذا رغم دخول الهدنه السادسه التي
وافق عليها الطرفان لمده 72 ساعه حيز
التنفيذ
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كندا خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات كيف
يبدو المشهد الميداني في السودان مع تواصل
المواجهات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
لليوم السابع عشر وما هي المقالات
المحتمله للاوضاع في ضوء استمرار القتال
وما هي الاستراتيجيه التي يتبناها طرفها
القتال في العمليات التي يقومان بها ضد
بعضهم البعض وما هي الاسباب التي اطالت
امد المواجهات بينهما
وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان نفهم الاهداف
الاستراتيجيه التي يسعى كل طرف لتحقيقها
عبر مواصله القتال وما هي السيناريوهات
التي يمكن ان تنتهي اليها
المواجهات بين الطرفين
[موسيقى]
على واقع قصف لطائرات الجيش السوداني ترد
عليه قوه دعم السريع بالمضادات الارضيه
ومع اشتباكات استخدمت فيها مختلف انواع
الاسلحه امضت العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
يومها الاول من الهدنه السادسه التي اعلن
طرفها القتال للمفارقه التزامهما بها لمده
ثلاثه ايام منتصف ليله الاحد الاثنين
بتوقيت السودان
القصف الجوي ورد المضادات الارضيه عليه
تركز في احياء كافوري وشمبات والصباب وحلت
خوجه لي وضاحيه الحلفايه الواقعه جميعها
في الخرطوم بحري احدى المدن اثلاث المكونه
للعاصمه السودانيه كما تجاوزها ليصل
الجانب الشرقي من جزيره توتي في مدينه
الخرطوم
ادخنه القتال استمر الجيش والدعم السريع
في تبادل الاتهامات بخرق الهدنه وارتكاب
انتهاكات تفاوتت بين قصف الاحياء السكنيه
ومواقع الخدمات الطبيه والاحتماء
بالمدنيين واتخاذهم دروعا بشريه هذا
بموازاه تاكيد كل طرف تحقيق التقدم على
الارض من دون توفر معلومات محايده عن
نتائج القتال
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا بن باريس محمد
تورشين الكاتب والباحث السياسي السوداني
ومن عمان معنى فايزه الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي والذي معه سنبدا
بالنقاش مرحبا بكما سيد فايز اليوم طوي
اليوم السابع عشر من
القتال بين الدعم السريع وقوات الجيش في
السودان لكن ما زالت الضبابيه تحكم المشهد
العسكري على الارض حتى اللحظه هل لك ان
تعطينا تقييما لما وصلت اليه الامور بعد
17 يوما من القتال
يعني علينا ان نعود الى اليوم الاول
والثاني في اليوم الاول والثاني بعد
اندلاع القتال كان الحديث من جانب قوات
الرد السريع حديث المنتصر وبان الامور في
طريقها للحسم السريع لماذا استنادا الى
تصور معين ان قوات الرد السريع وهذه قراءه
كانت مستعده للحدث وهي التي بادرت بالحدث
استنادا الى
حجم القوه وطريقه انتشار هذه القوه ويبدو
ان تقييمها لرد فعل الجيش السوداني لم يكن
دقيقا لكن ما ان انتهت اول 48 ساعه قام
الجيش السوداني بامتصاص الصدمه انجاز
التعبير وبدا في التعامل مع الاحداث بدا
باستخدام اوراق القوه الرئيسيه لديه واهم
هذه الاوراق هي سلاح الجو وبالتالي
المعسكرات بدا يهاجم نقاط التزويد بدا
يهاجم المعاقل الرئيسيه يهاجم التعزيزات
فبدات الامور تتجه باتجاه مصلحه القوات
المسلحه السودانيه وبالتالي بدانا نشاهد
ان المعارك بصوره عامه هي اقرب الى
اشتباكات بعيده واستخدام القصف الناري
اكثر من الدخول بمعارك
صداميه او معارك مباشره هناك قصد وهناك رد
فعل سواء ضد الجو او ضد الارض دعني اقول
خلال 17 يوما الماضيه تحول القتال
لمصلحه الجيش السوداني وبدا بفرض السيطره
التدريجيه وان كان لا يزال يواجه العديد
من العقبات في فرض السيطره الكليه وهذا
التاخر له مسبباته اهم مسببات هي البعد
السياسي لهناك سته اتفاقيات لوقف اطلاق
النار هي هدى ولكن انا اسميها تهدئه
وبعضها جاء انسجاما ورغبه وتحقيقا
للتطلعات الاجلاء
وبالتالي كان مجبرا على على قبول هذه
المبادرات مع التحضير لما بعد كل مبادره
على الرغم انها لم تطبق على كل
في هذه الغدن نعم السيد فايز لماذا لماذا
طالت المعركه حتى هذا الوقت وربما قد تطول
اكثر هذا سناتي على على نقاشه بالتفصيل
معك ولكن بما انك اتيت على ذكر الهدى سيدي
محمد طورشين
من الاحرص من الجانبين برايك على الهدنه
والتقاط الانفاس بعد 17 يوما من الق تال
المشاهدين الكرام وظيفه الكريم انا في
تقديري من خلال المعطيات التي ظننا
نتابعها من خلال وسائل الاعلام وكذلك بعض
المصادر التي تعيش في السودان تؤكد لنا
بان الطرفين لا يحترمونها الهدن التي تم
اطلاقها منا هدنه الساعتين وحتى الهدنه
السادسه التي بدات اليوم وهنالك اختراعات
ظلت مستمره لماذا لانه كل طرف يدعم من
خلال هذه الهدنه
عوامل او الاشياء مهمه جدا منها عمليه
الحجز والتحشير باعتبار ان الدعم السريع
اعتمد في هذه الهدن انه يستطيع استقطاب
اعراضه الموجوده في دارفور في كردفان بعض
المناطق القوات المسلحه ايضا استطاع عناصر
قادمه من نهر النيل وكذلك من شر السودان
فبالتالي كله طرف يدعى الى تعزيز مقامنا
القوى اثناء هذه الهدن باي حال من الاحوال
الجزئيه الاخرى المهم ايضا كل طرف يدعى
حتى لا يتم تصنيفه بانه لا راقب في الاست
في قضايا الهدنه حتى يتثنى للاجانب كذلك
الخروج من السودان او الجساد الدبلوماسي
فضلا عن ذلك رغبته بشكل مستمر في التواصل
الى تفاهمات او تسويه الصراع هذا فيلميا
وبالتالي اذا رفض هذه الهدى سيصبح اكثر
عزله وهذا التصريح الذي ادى به المبعوثه
الامريكي وكذلك
المبعولكرم الامم المتحده للسودان فكل هذه
العوامل لتجعل الاطراف فتمضي نحو الهدنه
او الهدنه التي مضت دون ان تكون هنالك
اراده ورغبه حقيقيه باعتبار منذ الوهله
الاولى ظللنا نسمع لتصريحات الطرقيه الصرع
بان الحسم ينبغي ان يكون عسكريا وانا في
تقديري هذه هي المؤشرات التي ظهرت منذ
الوهله الاولى لان الطرفين كانوا على ما
التفاوت وكانوا وصلوا الى
المتقدمين لكن عندما اتى الحديث حول القيد
الزمني لدمج الدعم المؤسسه العسكريه وكذلك
قضيه سيطره
السيطره والتح نعم فريق
كانت هذه هي القصه التي قسمت ظهر البيت
فبالتالي ايضا بان الحزم ينبغي ان يكون
عسكريا وهذا ما يمضي حاليا طيب اعود اليك
سيد فايز الدويري عندما اشرت الى ان
الامور تسير لمصلحه الجيش الذي يمتلك سلاح
الجو الذي بدا باستخدامه اثر يعني امتصاصه
للصدمه كما قلت لكن المساله طالت رغم ان
حسب تعبيرك الواقع الميداني لمصلحه الجيش
وهو يمتلك سلاح الجو ويستخدمه لكن عمليا
الامور ما زالت على الارض غير محسومه الى
متى برايك
يا سيدي اولا يعني انا لا استطيع ان اوصف
ما يجري بالسودان بانه قتال مدن بالمعنى
الحرفي لو كنا نوصف ذلك علينا ان نذهب الى
الموصل الى الانبار الى الرقه الى حلب الى
باقبوت وبالتالي طبيعه هذا القتال الان
وليس قتال مدن بالمعنى الحرفي هناك قوات
ذات قابليه حركه عاليه لديها العديد من
المعسكرات تتحرك كجماعات صغيره او كبيره
من منطقه الى اخرى تهاجم ومن ثم تنكفئ
وبالتالي طبيعه هذا القتال لا يمكن ان
يدرج تحت ما يسمى بقتال المدن ولو كنا
نتحدث عن قتال المدن بالمعنى الحرفي مدينه
بحجم السودان باركانها ثلاث ستاخذ سنوات
فاخمت عشره اشهر وهي 70 الف اكبر تعداد
سكاني الها اذا هنا دعنا نقول عمليات
عسكريه ما بين قوات قابليه حركه عاليه مع
جيش لديه عقيده القتاليه وثقافته
والتحديدات المفروضه عليه لماذا الجيش هو
يمثل باعتبار الدوله السوداني والامن
السوداني هذا ما يقوله ويعتبر القوات
الاخرى بانها قوات متمرده وبالتالي هو
يحاول ان يقدم صوره بانه يقاتل من اجل
الوطن وليس من انحاء من خلال الحاق الضرر
بالوطن لهذا سبب لم نشهد واؤكد لم نشهد
معارك حقيقيه انما هي عباره عن اشتباكات
مؤطره بمكان جغرافي واضرب مثال القصر
الجمهوري كانت توجد به قوات الدعم السريع
خلال 17 يوم لم يتم السيطره عليه واستعاده
السيطره الكامله للجيش يقدم اعذار انه
يحاط ب مدنيين ونحن نعمل بطريقه
الجراحيه باختصار فقط يعني هذه النقطه
التي تشير اليها
لم تؤدي الى النتيجه العسكريه التي
يتواخاها الجيش وبالتالي هل هو بحاجه الى
تغيير استراتيجيه ام ماذا
نعم نعم يعني هم الان تغيير الاستراتيجيه
قد تبدو عباره سهله ولكن
تغيير الاستراتيجيه يتطلب مجموعه كبيره من
العوامل اولا علينا ان ننظر الى القدرات
والامكانات المتاحه من اجل
تجسيد استراتيجيه قريبه ولكن دعني اشير
بعجاله
من صلب تكوين الجيش السوداني هناك ما يطلق
عليه القوات الخاصه وهناك قوات التدخل
السريع والتي اشار لها الفريق البرهان
هناك يوجد ثلاث الاف من قوات النخبه وعلى
غرار الجرين باريدس او النسور الزائقه
وغير ذلك وهذه القوات هي اصلا الارقى
تدريبا وتاهيلا وتسليحا لم نسمع عنها شيء
في استخدامها قال اذا دعني اقول هم بحاجه
الى قوه مشتركه
مختلطه من الجيش والمدفعيه والقوات الخاصه
وقوات المشاه وتاتي خلفها قوات الشرطه
لفرض الامن بعد الاستعاده وبالتالي هذا
كله يعتمد على منظومه استخباريه متكامله
تقدم المعلومه لان المعركه متحركه ولكن في
عجاله
من الصعب جدا ضمن بالرؤيه الحاليه ان يتم
استعاده السيطره الكامله على السودان
مدينه الخرطوم باركان الثلاث ضمن المدى
القصير القادم طيب
في مقابل ما ذكرته عن الجيش الدعم السريع
ايضا تكرر سيد فايز بانه
يتمتع بقدره حركه سريعه ومناوره اسهل
واسرع قياسا بما يمكن للجيش النظام ان
يقوم به وهذا يساعده على البقاء ونقل
المعارك داخل الخرطوم من منطقه الى اخرى
فضلا عن السيطره على او بالاحرى مشاركه
السيطره اذا صح التعبير على المراكز
الاساسيه والحيويه في الخرطوم سيد محمد
تيرشين طيب في الميزان العسكري هنا تحدثنا
في الميزان السياسي هل يسمح للجيش
نتيجه الواقع السياسي في السودان عرقيا
وقبليا وحتى سياسيا هل سيسمح بالحسم
العسكري
وهزيمه الدعم السريع
من ناحيه المقارنه الطبيعه وتركيبه القوات
المسلحه مع الدعم السريع هنالك مفارقات
كبيره جدا وان كانت الاقوات المسلحه
بقيادات العليا او الرتب العليا تنفذ الى
بعض المناطق الجغرافيه لكن في صفوف الرتب
الوسيطه وضباط الصف والجنود يشمل كل
المكونات الشعب السوداني بما في ذلك
المكون باذن الذي ينحذر منه محمد حمدان
ولا الاصطفاف القبر الذي يحظى به في
الجانب الاخر نتحدث عن الدعم السريع الدعم
السريع هي عباره عن مليشه الجندويت التي
ظلت ترتكب فضائح وانتهاكات في صفوف
المدنيين العذر في دارفور ابان الحرب منذ
اندلاع حتى توقيع اتفاقيه جبل السلام
متطورت واستثمرت بعض القيادات قيادات
المؤتمر الوطني البائس بعض الظروف
والصراعات التاريخيه داخل الحزب الحاكم
عندئذ الصراع الشهير بين الفريق طه عثمان
الحسين وكذلك مدير المخابرات الاصبع
فصراحه عبد الله غش استطاعت في ظهور هذه
الظروف ان تصعد وان تصبح قوه الجيش وكذلك
من المخابرات والشرطه عندما اصدر قانون
لقوات الدعم السريع في العام 2017 واصبحت
قوه منفصله وتم اشراكها في عاصفه الحزم في
اليمن فانا في تقديري ونتيجه لذلك استطاع
انه محمد حمدان ان يناور سياسيا الشعب
السوداني المتمثل في التغيير وحذرنا
وجود الدعم السريعي بهذه الشكليه في ظل
مؤسسات عسكريه ومعلومه ولديها تاريخها
الذي يفوق حتى تاريخ استقلال السوداني
ينبغي ان يدمج في المؤسسه العسكريه لكن
عند محمد حمدان دغري استطاع ان يمنح
العطايا وكذلك الايباد لكثير من قياده
القوى السياسيه والمعني هنا قوى الحريه
والتغيير لذا لم يستجيبوا لفتره دمج الدعم
السريع وعن جائزه كانت قوته
السيد محمد انطلاقا مما مما تشرح سالته
هل
سيكون من الطبيعي ومن السهل تمرير هزيمه
الدعم السريع في الواقع السوداني المعقد
اذا حصلت تلك الهزيمه
منطقيه يمكن ان يحدث ذلك بكل المعطيات لكن
المعادله مرتبطه ارتباط
قياده الدعم قياده الدعم السريع قادر انها
تخرج الان من الخرطوم وان تلتفت وتذهب الى
دارفور او كردفان ومن بعد دخول
كفاح مسلح او تعلن نفسها حركه عن النظام
الحاكم وابلغ فانا في تقدير اذا استطعت
هذه القيادات الخروج من الخرطوم يمكن ان
يحدث تاثير كبير وبعض على النتيجه
الاجتماعي في دارفور لكن اذا تم القاء
القبض عليها او سقطت اثناء هذه المعارك
ربما المعادله تكون اقل كلفه بحيث انه
والان لاحظنا العديد من المكونات
الاجتماعيه التي تنفرد في الدعم السريع
بدات تنسحب واعاده حساباتها الا المجموعات
التي لديها مصالح وتربطها بعض بواسيرات
والقرار والنفق مع قياده الدعم والسريعه
محمد حمدان
سيد فايز الدويري كيف يمكن ان يكون عليه
الحال اذا طالت المعارك واذا لم تتم هزيمه
الدعم السريع كيف يمكن ان يكون عليه وضع
الجيش في هذه الحاله والوضع العسكري في
الخرطوم
يا سيدي يعني في البدايه
في ظل الانسداد السياسي حتى اللحظه التي
اتحدث بها رغم الحديث عن امكانيه عقد لقاء
في جنوب السودان او في الرياض لكن اللحظه
الحاليه هناك انسداد سياسي الامر الاخر
دعنا ننظر الى المواقف السياسيه للطرفين
الفريق البرهاني يتحدث عن خروج قوات الدعم
السريع من الخرطوم
فيما بالمقابل ان الجانب الاخر يتحدث عن
القاء القبض على البرهان ومحاكمه وتقع
مجرم حرب لاحظ الفجوه كبيره جدا اذا
استمرار القتال سيبقى قائما وهنا دعني
اقسم السودان مجازا الى دائرتين الدائره
الاولى دائره الخرطوم والدائره الثانيه
الدائره السودانيه فحتى في حال حتى في حال
في الحاله الاول عدم حدوث حسم عسكري
واطاله امد المعركه هذا الى ماذا يقود
السودان بلد الثنائيات العرقيه الدينيه
المذهبيه اذا بلد الثنائيات
وبالتالي الصراع
سيتسع ويغطي بقيه الولايات الان يغطي ثلاث
ولايات
بصوره عامه بجانب الخرطوم اذا توسع القتال
فالمسار باتجاه حافه الهاويه وهو تفتيت
السودان ولا قدر الله وتقسيمه السيناريو
الاخر ان يتم استعاده السيطره على الخرطوم
وخروج القيادات وقسم من هذه القوه
وانتفائها الى معاقلها في كردفان او
دارفور هنا ندخل بمسار الليبي تبرق بنغازي
مقابل طرابلس
الخرطوم والقوات المسلحه مقابل كردفان
ودارفور للدعم السريع السيناريو الثالث
وهو الذي يتامل المجتمع الدولي به يعني
يشعر طرفي القتال ان امكانيه الحسم غير
وارده القدره القتاليه بدات تتاكل
للجانبين هنا لابد من اللقاء على طاوله
التفاوض وهنا يخرج عندنا السيناريو
الاثيوبي بعد عامين من القتال في اثيوبيا
هكذا اقرا المشهد
سيد محمد طورشين يعني نحن ايضا نحاول ان
[موسيقى]
نقرا المشهد من جانب التاثيرات وما يمكن
ان نحاول ان نستشرف المستقبل في ضوء ما
يحصل حاليا على الارض كان لافت في هذا
المجال ما يقوله فولكر بورس المبعوث
الاممي الى السودان عندما تخوف من دخول
قوه مسلحه وقبائل مسلحه على خط النزاع هذا
الامر ما خطورته من يقصد واين
وما تاثير ذلك على مستقبل السودان وشكل
السودان اذا حصل
هو طبعا المشهد السوداني فيه العديد من
التعقيدات لكن ينبغي ايضا ان نشير ونركز
على معلومه انه الدعم السريع هو لا ينتمي
او من مكون اجتماعي واحد وانما من عده
مكونات اجتماعيه فبالتالي هذه المكونات
ربما من المجموعات التي تاثرت تضررت حتى
من ممارسات من قبل فبالتالي باي حال من
الاحوالها لا يمكن ان نشكل بان الدعم
السريع سيكون قوه ضاربه اذا عاد الى
دارفور وانا في تقدير المساله حتكون اكثر
تعقيدا باعتبار ان المكونه الاجتماعي او
جزء من المكون الاجتماعي بالاخص مجموعه
المهريه التي ينتمي اليها الدعم السريع
لديها اشكاليات مع كل القبائل الموجوده في
دارفور وهذا في حد ذاته يحاول انها رؤيه
مستقبل اذاعات الدعم السريعي المنتصرا او
مهزوما الى دارفور بحيث انه في الاحداث
التي حدثت في الجنينه مؤخرا راينا ان
هنالك بعض الاطراف سواء من مجموعه
المساليد او المجموعات الاخرى حاولت ان
تدعم المواطنين بمنحهم بعض الاسلحه وفتح
مستودعات الزخاير وما الى ذلك فانا في
تقديري تداعي لذلك ستكون وقيمه باعتبار
انه ستكون هنالك حرب اهليه مفتوحه في ظل
اصلا من قبل الصراحه حول السلطه والثروه
والموارد وكذلك هذا الصراع موجود في
كردفان الى حد ما في شخص السودان اما فيما
تبقى السودان لا يتاثر كثيرا بهذه
المعطيات فضلا عن ذلك ينبغي ان نؤكد بان
هنالك تداخل قبلي كبير جدا بين السودان
وبانشات وكذلك السودان وافريقيا الوسطى
والدولتين بهم اضطرابات كثيره هذا عمليه
التدخل اطراف او انتاج مجموعات الى
السودان وكذلك يسهل عمليه الحصول على
السلاح وكذلك هذه المعادله ندرجها في
افريقيا الوسطى عن ذلك هنالك ليبيا هنالك
مساحات شاسعه والصحراء متسعه يمكن ايضا ان
تساهم في هذا الصراع هل يعد طرفان برايك
لكل هذه المخاطر التي تذكرها
الذين دعموا صرحوا بان ينبغي ان تكون هذه
الحرب قبلي قبل اندلاع الان راينا مريم
الصادق بدات تتحدث هو تدعو الى مراجعه
الذات وهي من الذين تحدث على ضروره ان
تكون هذه الحرب يعني متاحه فالنفي تقدير
الكل كان لا يعلم الحرب الحرب في كل سنوات
الماضيه السودان لم ينتمي بها الا ابناء
دارفور وكذلك النيل الازرق والجنوب كردفان
وشرق السودان مجتمعه الخرطوم ومجتمعات
السودان لم تتاثر بالحرب كثيرا لكن في
غضون الاسبوعين التي مضت انا في تقدير
كثير من المعطيات وكثير من النظره الى ان
الحرب ستحل الازمه السودانيه ستتغير في
مقبل الايام والان تغيرت بحيث انه الحرب
انا في تقدير لم تظهر شيئا الان البنيه
التحتيه تحطمت تماما الان القوه السياسيه
لديها رغبه ان يكون هنالك تفاهمات سياسيه
باعتبار انه الازمه في السودان هي الصراحه
والسلطه والثروه او الموارد وهذا الصراع
انا في تقديري الكل يعلم مالاته تداعياته
لكن رغبه تكون طرف بان يكون هو المتحكم
وهو المسيطر على المشهد الذي دفعت الطرفين
الى هذه المعارك باختصار سيد فايز الدويري
يعني بعد كل هذه الجلجله السؤال المركزي
النهائي الحسم العسكري مازال ممكنا برايك
ممكن لكن يحتاج الى وقت ولا اعاده
صياغه المقاربه العسكريه بطريقه مختلفه
عما هي الان ولكن ستكون فاتوره التكاليف
باهظه جدا ولهذا انا اميل الى مقاربه اخرى
اضعاف القدرات العسكريه
للرد السريع اضعاف القدرات العسكريه للدعم
السريع بحيث تجبره على القبول بمقاربه
سياسيه تعطيه حجم الحقيقي ولا تمنحه ولو
النزوع الى السيطره على السودان لابد من
اضعاف قدراته القتاليه وهذا المنهج الذي
تسير به القوات المسلحه وهذا يحتاج الى
وقت
البيت الابيض في نهايه هذه الحلقه البيت
الابيض يقول بانه يتشارك مع حلفائه
المعلومات الاستخباراتيه بشان الوضع في
السودان بهذا ناتي الى ختام هذه الحلقه
نشكر فايز دواري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي كان معنا من عمان ونشكر محمد
تورشين الكاتب والبحث السياسي السوداني
الذي كان معنا من باريس
ونشكر متابعتكم مشاهدينا تنتهي حلقتنا
الان من برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]